les discothèques resteront bien fermé au
delà du mois de juin le conseil d'état a
rejeté la requête de plusieurs patrons
de boîtes de nuit les réclamer la
réouverture de leur établissement à la
fin du mois de juin pour la haute
juridiction le maintien de leur
fermeture n'est pas disproportionnée au
regard de la situation sanitaire
les discothèques restent les grandes
absentes du calendrier du déconfinement
du gouvernement et pour en parler avec
nous morgan dalle il est propriétaire
d'une discothèque à béthune bonjour
morgan d'aller merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france le conseil a
donc rejeté cette demande de réouverture
des discothèques le 30 juin en attendant
des concerts tests vont avoir lieu fin
mai les mariages reprendront avec des
jauges et les impôts vos feux à 21h à
partir du 9 juin puis librement à
compter du 30 juin des décisions que
vous jugez jugé injuste alors tout
d'abord je voudrais rappeler que c'est
toute la profession qui a saisi le
conseil d'état c'est à dire que ce sont
tous les syndicats dont les discothèques
alors il faut deux choses cette décision
qui est en conseil d'état
c'est pour vous premier temps nous
fatigue le choix du cargo qui est
correct il est bon on n'est pas illégal
mais dans un second temps le conseil
d'état nous rappelle qu' ils reviennent
lorsque au 30 juin on autorisera les
concerts de plus de 5000 personnes ainsi
que les rassemblements de plus 1000
personnes les fêtes de mariage et les
bars musicaux à travailler il reviendra
au gouvernement d'assurer que les
différentes les différentes restrictions
sont cohérentes entre elles
c'est à dire qu'on nous ouvre une porte
c'est à dire qu'on nous indique très
précisément que lorsqu on autorisera des
des lieux qui diffusent de la musique
amplifiée à travailler de façon nocturne
alors il faudra si également soit
autoriser les discothèques ou si on les
laisse fermer les indemniser de façon à
recchi
rééquilibrer cette inégalité en tout cas
cet été et discothèques ne comprend pas
il y aura trois fait même qu'ils vont se
passer c'est à dire qu'il y aura un an
sauvagement de nos centres villes
il y aurait également une risque de
quatrième vague sait très bien que nos
jeunes ne seront pas encadré et une fois
de plus on assistera à une nouvelle
délocalisation qui sera la
délocalisation du secteur de la nuit de
la culture nuit vers nos pays voisins
nos c'est à dire pourquoi la grèce et
l'angleterre
donc nous sommes très active et parce
que on observe que tous nos voisins sont
en train de rouvrir leur discothèque
sauf que la france qui est leur aplomb
rappelons le le le paie là des pays les
plus restrictifs actuellement donc voilà
en tout cas cause dans quelques mois
voire dans quelques années on il y aura
un inventaire qui sera fait on regardera
en arrière et on se posera on regardera
on se posera les questions en se
demandant pourquoi les discothèques
étaient restés fermés
si c'est le cas si c'est ce qui se passe
cet été alors qu'on a laissé des fêtes
de mariage avoir lieu et c est ce qu il
aurait été envisageable selon vous de
rouvrir mais avec un protocole sanitaire
particulier vous vous y avez pensé qu
est ce que vous vous étiez prêts à a
proposé au gouvernement pour pouvoir
rouvrir sur ce sujet je vais pas on a à
peu perdu parce que le le modem donc et
dans la majorité avait déposé un
amendement pour que les discothèques
puisse rouvrir avec un pass sanitaires
cela a été rejeté et balaye est balayée
par par la république en marche pour que
le lendemain la reine propose à un texte
de loi pour que le passé ni texte soit
instaurée pour tous les français c'est à
dire que la veille le modem déposer un
nom de qliktech rouvrent avec un pass
annie terre et les lentes et qui est
donc est balayée par la république en
marché leurs ma il propose ci propose un
texte pour toute la population française
c'est à dire que même impasse annie
terre il n'en est même pas question un
protocole nous n'avons pas
données scientifiques nous n'avons pas
de conseils scientifiques pas de conseil
de sécurité pas de cabinet de conseil
donc nous attendons que le ministère de
la santé nous oriente et ensuite on
verra si nous on souhaite ouvrir ou non
mais c'est mais cette on n'est pas dans
cet été cet état d'esprit là c'est à
dire que cette démarche n'est pas n'est
pas encore présente
quelles sont les conséquences
économiques pour vous jusqu'à présent de
cette fermeture qui dure depuis plus
d'un an
les conséquences économiques c'est que
actuellement est à peu près 150
discothèque qui ont fermé ce qui
représente au bas mot 1500 emplois on
s'aperçoit que personne ne s'en inquiète
peu de politique
alors que lorsqu'on parle d'un d'une
fermeture d'usinés comme celle de
bridgestone
on aperçoit toutes les oppositions tous
les partis politiques intervenir pour
renaître des cendres de cette entreprise
qui ferme
donc on est un peu on a un peu surpris
que lorsque 150 entreprises mettent la
clé sous la porte
ça ne fait pas la une des médias donc il
faut pas oublier que le secteur de la
vie nocturne sa pop et 45 mille emplois
c'est plus d'un milliard de chiffre
d'affaires
et alors à l'heure d'aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas nous ne sommes pas en mesure
nous ne pouvons pas se payer ce luxe de
faire une croix sur un milliard de
chiffre d'affaires
je veux dire à l'heure où on nous parle
en permanence de la stat de la start up
nation
il est temps de remettre tout le monde
au travail d'envoyer un message positif
à tous les entrepreneurs en leur disant
continuer à entreprendre car de toute
façon nous nous vous aiderons à
travailler et nous empêcheront pas de
bosser seront réhabilités corse contexte
1600 encore plus de travail c'est un peu
con merci beaucoup
morgane dalle d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
propriétaire d'une discothèque à béthune
merci à vous